Le papa pingouin
Le papa pingouin s'ennuie sur la banquise
Le papa pingouin voudrait faire sa valise
On le sent nerveux
Un peu malheureux
Pas très bien dans ses plumes
Pour se calmer les nerfs
Il plonge dans la mer
Il envie l'oiseau
Qui s'en va là-haut du côté de la lune
Lui qui a des pieds de plomb
Ça le rend grognon
Le papa pingouin
Le papa pingouin s'ennuie sur la banquise
Le papa pingouin s'ennuie sur sa valise
Sur la neige bleue
Fait un pas douteux
Et glisse sur la glace
On l'entend murmurer
Je veux m'en aller
Très haut dans le ciel
Tout près du soleil
En traversant l'espace
J'ai les ailes d'un oiseau
Je peux voler haut
Mais voyons Papa
Pourquoi dis-tu ça?
Tu sais bien que les ailes
Celles des pingouins et des moulins
Ne servent plus à rien
Mais pourquoi, Papa
Aller là bas?
Ici la vie est belle
Laisse le ciel aux anges et aux saints
Vient Papa
Le papa pingouin
Le papa pingouin poursuit son jolie rêve
Voilà qu'il se prend
Pour un goéland
Il fait de longs voyages
Il descend vers le sud
Jusqu'en Angleterre
Et voici Paris
Et même Napoli
Les rives de Carthage
La Méditerranée
Que c'est beau l'été
Mais voyons papa
Tu ne penses pas
Tu sais bien que les ailes
Des pingouins et des moulins
Ne servent plus à rien
Mais pourquoi papa
Allez là-bas ?
Ici la vie est belle
Si tu pars tu n'iras pas loin
Reste là Papa
Le papa pingouin
Le papa pingouin revient de ses chimères
Le papa pingouin redescend sur la Terre
Le papa pingouin
Le papa pingouin adore sa banquise
Le papa pingouin va brûler sa valise
Le papa pingouin